une victoire au bout du suspense
villepreux a réussi à se qualifier pour
le deuxième tour de la coupe de france
grâce à ce coup franc zidanesque
pourtant rien n'a été simple pour les
villes prodi en face à draveil
mené 1 0 et réduits à dix en début de
match les rouges auraient agi pour me
les deux cousins avant la mi temps
malheureusement non prend un rouge un
peu à mon pic a accepté malgré qui
fixait les règles ils font 5 6 7 8 aux
tirs ont pas carton à dix contre onze on
est en train de faire du 2 1 on continue
le travail qu'on est en train de faire
depuis des matches des matches
le travail va finir par payer à la fin
au retour des vestiaires les villes
prises en souffrent face au pensionnaire
de deuxième division de district draveil
fini par égaliser à deux buts partout
sur corner enfin quand on est revenu on
en sait du compte on défend des
solidaires et on a défendu peut-être un
peu trop bas un but encaissé qui a servi
d'électrochoc villepreux poussé fini par
marquer le but de la victoire dans les
dernières secondes
score final 3 buts à 2 sa délivrance
c'est le résultat de deux mois deux mois
de travail une délivrance allait jouer
une équipe eu une division au dessus on
va en fusion comme il a dit 80 minutes à
dix c'est compliqué c'est là la
récompense comme je le redis dans le
petit message ça reste la coupe de
france c'est la télé qui vient il ya les
supporters sont là et ainsi de suite
faites vous plaisir avant tout ce sera
un résultat prochain tour pour villes
pro début juin contre un adversaire
encore inconnu les supporters eux
commence à prendre goût à la coupe de
foot